most of the investing in the seed
community is not driven by true angels
it's driven by VCS and seed funds and
most of the reactive Angeles we've
actually gotten deals done with entries
and Greylock kleiner you know a lot of
top firms first-round you know etc etc
so a deal that's done a person posts
onto angel list one of those partners at
the sees it it takes a meeting and then
it originated from angel is correct and
so IND rates at harvest on those kind of
people they just think Oh
Angeles is just another great source yes
especially with a little extra vetting
right especially for the top tier VCS
they love it because they know they can
get into any deal so more visibility and
more deals being created as good for
them I think really the VCS who may not
be as happy about it are the ones who
had a proprietary access to some very
narrow deal flow like they were sitting
as a bottleneck in some university or
some location where nobody else was
around the proprietary access deal flows
going away everyone knows everything now
information is free right so all and
this is one of the last strangle hugs
really of like this is one of the last
opaque boxes private company funding at
the early stages right and it'll take
ten years to unravel fully but it will
right and some people are kicking and
screaming but generally speaking the
great companies will rise and the great
investors will rise right and the
mediocre ones will take a big hit
and so that's right and so as an
investor you have to compete on your
judgment and on your and basically on
your brand your value reputation right
but you don't get to compete on your
proprietary access right or the fact
that you just happen to be a VC with a
checkbook right that alone is not enough
anymore right there's too much capital
in this world looking for a return right
and is this creating are you are you
creating more angel investors do you
think I don't think so because we've
actively resisted that so some of our
criteria for getting listed as an angel
and angel this is you have to have done
at least two pure cash investments in
the past and you have to have be someone
a reputation a community that we can
check out and of course you have to be
accredited so really what we're trying
to proxy underneath is have you lost
money before and been okay with it right
but we only want people who are not
going to get bent out of shape
when the entrepreneur loses the money so
in that sense we're really not trying to
create new investors the space is highly
regulated and there's a lot of
litigation in it so we don't want to get
sued when that person loses their money
right so you know we don't really view
ourselves as a vetting or training
ground for new investors how do new
angel investors then get trained
I mean Angelus doesn't exist for that
purpose it exists for a different
purpose what what is the mechanism for
that because I see a lot of angel angels
and training people who want to be angel
investors coming to the events I host
and then getting on AngelList or asking
me for a referral to Angel those kind of
thing I think generally for those people
the best thing is to invest with someone
you know alongside into one or two deals
get your feet wet invest in people that
you know learn a little bit go to an
incubator demo day see the lay of the
land make your mistakes there yeah
exactly
which is exactly what's happened I had
two or three people who wanted to be
angel investors and they said I want to
invest in something at launch can i
invest in something I said no well you
have to make that decision myself
yeah we've rejected 75 or 80 percent of
the angel applicants AngelList Wow Wow
seven eight out of ten yeah that's a
significant number yeah we could easily
be at twelve thirteen thousand investors
we want it to be right but you just
don't want the adjective having to plus
the startup scare the startups like who
is this person right right the better
the startup the more they care about who
gets to see their profile who's in their
own back to your original point about
signaling and if you care who have your
investor you probably have something
worth caring about right